hi there
uh day 12. well i had a fairly good day
today language learning wise
you can hear my wife playing the piano
in the background we just came back from
dinner at our son's place with
my son's mother-in-law and of course his
family and we had a great time there as
usual nice meal
um read a fair amount in um
my that book with the patterns that
japanese book
read three articles from chosen ilbo and
i'm starting to get that feeling you
know when you have that feeling that you
have the wind in your sails
that i'm understanding these newspaper
articles better
i have a couple of discussions lined up
for tomorrow with our tutors at link
we'll see how those go
i had an interview for an hour with
david manceray who is
part of that sort of community of
polyglots on the internet and he is
involved in a project
and the subject of our discussion was
age and
language learning and of course i said
that age has essentially very little to
do with language learning
perhaps in the first seven eight nine
years of your life your brain is more
flexible but thereafter
i'm firmly convinced that it's more
attitude
uh you know sometimes people are in
their 30s or 40s they're they resist the
language why does that language say it
differently well that's a stupid way to
say it
they cling to their own culture they
don't want to look silly
those kinds of attitudinal things are
are the the obstacle not anything in our
brains i believe that i'm a better
language learner today at age 68 than i
was at age 16
not only because i have more experience
but also because the technology has
changed the availability of i mean
mp3 players the internet and all of
these kinds of things it just makes it
so much easier to learn
and that brings up another subject which
i'm going to talk about briefly and that
is optimism
i believe i'm a better language learner
today than i was at 16. i believe i can
do it
and i think the belief that we can do
things is extremely important to
language learning in other words i
believe i can get better i believe that
every day that i put effort in whether
it's an hour or three hours reading
listening speaking
however much i stumble however much i
struggle
i know that it is contributing towards
my improvement i'm convinced of it i'm
an optimist
i ge i have given myself a 90-day period
in which to make a significant
improvement i will make that significant
improvement i'm quite convinced i'm an
optimist and i think
optimism is important to language
learning
i think optimism is important to life i
get very annoyed
when i read these sort of negative
comments about today that you know we're
ruining the planet
politicians are all corrupt it's not
worthwhile voting
uh capitalism consumerism is destroying
the world i mean
it that is just absolute absolute
nonsense
by any standard
we are so much better off today than at
any time before in history
life expectancy was 30 half or more of
children who were born died
if there was a poor harvest some year
because it was cold or rained too much
people had nothing to eat
nowadays
we can eat
produce from
california spain
indonesia it doesn't matter and then
there are people who complain we should
only eat the local produce what a bunch
of nonsense again if therefore if you're
in sweden all you get to eat is potatoes
and herring you shouldn't have citrus
fruit because it's not local
of course we're better off to be able to
access food from all over the world and
those countries that export their
produce they're better off because
they're able to export it it's a
wonderful world uh we have seven and a
half billion people on the planet for
the longest time we had the same you
know a few hundred million so
of course it has an impact on
certain ecosystems but that doesn't mean
the world is being destroyed it means
that
there's been a growth in the human
population which has perhaps caused
certain constraints on some other
populations we should try to mitigate
that we should try to mitigate it and
there's been efforts in many countries
to revive populations of certain
wildlife and so forth and so on but it's
no disaster even this great global
warming thing we don't know what these
consequences might be there's a number
of different scenarios what we do know
is that more and more people are living
longer and longer
we have
people are eating better people are less
hungry than they used to be at any time
in history at any time in history i mean
uh
you know the sort of noble savage living
in the bush he was forever in danger of
getting
dying from hunger from disease in the
next battle i mean warfare was endemic
violence was endemic i mean we have a
much better life today despite all the
problems now that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't work to resolve the problems
yes there is inequality and most
countries have some form of
redistributing wealth and providing you
know uh benefits to people and so on and
so on but overwhelming people can travel
now uh you know i'm listening to
sort of on my mp3 player uh listening to
uh you know mozart who could listen to
mozart back in whenever he lived 1780 or
something the few wealthy at the court
and now anyone who wants to listen to
mozart can listen to mozart
not anyone but a very high percentage of
people can access that
sound and listen to it on some kind of
device you get the people on the
internet saying you know why vote that's
stupid don't believe the bs the
government tells you and the system is
crooked and everything is crooked well
then go and be a politician but vote
because what's the alternative to voting
revolution in the streets what does that
do that's power to the loudest and the
noisiest and the troublemakers no go and
do your duty and if you want to be a
politician if you think they're all
corrupt you go and be a politician so
all i'm saying is nothing is perfect
and when we try to impose perfection we
usually get tremendous distortions as we
saw in the 20th century the world we
live in today with all its imperfections
is amazing it's amazingly wonderful and
i think we should enjoy
the means that we have and the
increasing
you know
opportunities to solve problems to
spread education so i'm an optimist i
think we live in a wonderful world and i
think it can only get better and i think
we need to stay positive not only about
our language learning but about the
world we live in as a whole
thank you tomorrow i'll get back to
language learning and the 90-day
challenge